this is outperforming imperative with
pure functional languages i'm richard
feldman so for the past couple years
i've been working on building a
programming language called rock and
rock is inspired by and a direct
descendant of my what has been my
favorite programming language for
several years now which is l
um elm is one of the things that i love
about it is it's got this really
delightful user experience it really
gives me joy to program in it
it's a pure functional language and it's
compiled to javascript so it's really
good for making browser-based uis but
i've wanted sort of like an like
experience in other domains besides
browser-based uis and so rock has
similar goals to album of having like a
delightful user experience and it's a
pure functional programming language
like elm but it's compiled to binary so
it's sort of for other use cases that
elm is not meant for at the moment
um so i first got into elm based on this
blog post blazing fast html and elm
which came out in 2014
and one of the things that i appreciated
about elm was i had a relatively
performance sensitive ui that i was
building and i really like to see this
benchmark that sort of gave me
confidence that i was gonna have a fast
experience when i was building my apps
in element i wasn't gonna have a nice
experience building it and then have
things run slowly when i got done
um so i wanna sort of keep that value in
rock like it's really important to me
that like hey let's go fast let's let's
build a programming language that runs
programs really fast
of course the trouble with that is that
this is a pure functional programming
language and pure functional programming
languages are all about pure functions
as in like every function is pure and
that means
no side effects and no mutation which
can be a bit of a challenge when it
comes to performance if you're trying to
go really fast because
the fact of the matter is some
algorithms just require in-place
mutation to run fast
um like for example how competitive
could a pure functional language
possibly be at a mutation-heavy
algorithm like quicksort this seems like
somewhat of an intractable unavoidable
downside
so fortunately though there are several
different considerations to performance
like for example the language overhead
like how much overhead does the language
introduce sort of how close can it get
you to what the hardware is capable of
and that can be sort of balanced against
you know there's no side effects there's
no mutation so when you put all those
things together how well can we come out
when compared to imperative languages
well let's let's kind of look through
these and just talk through them so
first going to talk about language
overhead like in general and also as it
pertains to rock
um so
haskell is a very well known probably
the most well known uh pure functional
programming language um and we actually
use it at work where i work at no red
ink so our back end for many years was
ruby on rails which is a pretty common
tech stack uh and then in recent years
we've actually been migrating our our
back end from ruby to haskell and so in
particular we migrated one of our
services actually our most high traffic
performance critical service to haskell
this is serving billions of questions
every year we make software for english
teachers so students are answering
billions of questions on our site um all
going through this haskell service
and what we found was that when we
migrated this from ruby and rails to
haskell and service basically doing the
same job as it was doing before slightly
different but not really that meaningful
from a performance perspective um the
delta was quite large in terms of
performance it was about 10x faster
now this we're well aware was not
because like pure functional programming
is like oh that that's it's this magic
sauce that just makes everything run
faster um no it's definitely wasn't that
it's just because some
imperative versus uh pure functional but
they just sort of dominated in this case
which led to haskell being a lot more uh
performance in practice than ruby was
um
so let's talk about that execution model
a little bit i mentioned that ruby's
interpreted um there's quite a few
languages that we'll do interpreted
basically like interpreting the source
code into parsing it into an ast and
then interpreting that on the fly so
python ruby javascript i'll do this may
or may not have jit which is a
just-in-time compilation which can speed
that up in like really uh tight loops
things like that um some languages do
interpreted by codes so like java
c-sharp elixir compiling to beam by code
other languages go straight to a binary
like a
just an individual stand-alone binary so
go does this swift does this haskell
also does this
these are generally the fastest category
of things like these are pretty much
sorted from sort of highest overhead to
least overhead
but there's something that's worth
calling out as almost a different
category onto its own which is llvm
compiled to binary so llvm is basically
a library that's for optimizing uh
compiled binaries um it's not like llvm
is like the only way to get this uh this
extra speed bump but um languages like c
plus plus and rust and zig all use this
to get like really really exceptionally
great performance out of their binaries
and of course that's what we want for
rock too so that's what we've been using
um i mentioned boxing so boxing
basically referring to things being
allocated on the heap which generally is
a lot slower than allocating them on the
stack or in registers
some things that can be boxed include
numbers so like in python numbers are
boxed for example um that means that
doing number stuff in python is
generally a lot slower and why you have
libraries like numpy and stuff to speed
that back up um objects and records also
very commonly boxed depending on the
language
functions and closures also potentially
box depending on the language
basically uh you know that that's just
sort of another source of potential
slowness
memory management lots of different
memory management strategies a really
common one sort of the old school way
was like individual allocations and d
allocations like c c plus plus rust and
zig these languages will help you out
with this they're not going to make you
do it by hand like you had to and see
like every single allocation
specifically call malik and then call
free again um but at the end of the day
like that is how the memory is being
managed it's sort of like one allocation
at a time um then you also have tracing
garbage collectors which is a very very
popular strategy these days so like go
javascript haskell also like java and
the list goes on and on for tracing gcs
um big downside of tracing garbage
collectors compared to individual
allocations and d allocations is that
you get garbage collection pauses so
this is all something that we're
probably familiar with um you know the
program just locks up for for some
period of time while it's doing this
garbage collection there's another
memory management strategy that does not
have garbage collection pauses which is
quite nice um which is automatic
reference counting so python swift and
rock all do this and the usual downside
there is just that the reference
counting sort of has more overall
overhead typically so that sort of the
throughput is less compared to tracing
garbage collector even though you don't
have the gc pauses
um one of the things that you can do to
sort of reduce that downside and make it
so that it has higher throughput without
reintroducing gc pauses is what's known
as static reference counting i know that
swift does this in some form but i'm not
a swift programmer not sure exactly how
it works um but i know what we did in
rock to do this uh was there these two
papers that we implemented one is called
counting immutable beans the other is
called perseus and basically these are
two ways of among other things
optimizing it so that you don't need to
do as many reference checks at runtime
as many reference count operations at
runtime because we're able to sort of
detect at compile time where they would
be happening and cancel each other out
and we can just kind of throw them
away um one other thing i want to note i
don't have time to get all the way into
it for this talk but um there's another
thing that rock does that's a pretty
novel in terms of memory management the
upshot of it is that instead of using
automatic reference counting you can
completely transparently to the
application author in some situations uh
do arena allocation bump allocation
which are just way faster than any of
these other strategies including tracing
gc including even like individual
allocations and deallocations um i gave
a whole talk about this uh so if you're
curious about that you can you can check
it out later but suffice it to say um
this is one of the things that i think
is going to be most promising for rock's
long-term memory management even though
for the rest of this talk i'm not going
to be using it
um okay so to sum up when it comes to
language overhead we've basically tried
to do as good of a job when we can of
minimizing the language overhead of rock
so we're using llvm that's like
basically sort of the gold standard for
high performance compiling to binaries
today
we're using unboxed values basically
everywhere we possibly can there aren't
any values that i know of that are boxed
unnecessarily
and when it comes to memory management
we're doing static reference counting
along with uh some more exotic stuff
like arena allocation behind the scenes
um
so overall i'm like feeling pretty good
about this like okay i think we're doing
a good job here um good start but uh
that's that was sort of the upside
section right now we have these two
things we have to deal with which is
we're not allowed to do side effects
we're not allowed to do mutation so how
do we compete when those are our
restrictions so let's talk about the no
side effects thing well unfortunately of
the two this one turns out to not be as
big of a deal as you might guess
a common question that i hear asked of
people who talk about pure functional
programming languages is are you just
heating the cpu up
side effects are like everything so i
mean like what are you doing um pascal
doesn't do side effects like how is most
of our production traffic running on
haskell is it just like not doing any
effects is it never talking to database
no of course not it's doing all those
effects they're just not side effects
still effects but they are now managed
effects
so side effects versus managed effects
that's really the trade-off we're
talking about here when it comes to
performance
so here's an example of something that
does side effects this is javascript uh
doing using promises so we're setting
promise one equals fetch some url
promise two is fetch the url dot then
and then there's some callback which is
gonna return another promise you could
chain these together et cetera et cetera
promises are a super common thing in
javascript they're nice for modeling
asynchronous tasks that can sort of be
chained together and it's something that
is done all over the imperative world
managed effects now hold on because this
is going to look extremely different
as you can see this is super different
and weird and alien um no it's the same
thing
it's basically just promises the only
the only difference is like this is an
elm syntax so it's a little bit
different instead of a dot then you have
a pipe to and then but same basic thing
um so if you ever look at a like large
pure functional program structurally
it's very very similar to promises um
the only difference is that with
promises
right when you instantiate the promise
it runs the effect like as soon as you
call fetch boom it does the http request
right then and there whereas with
managed effects it's basically you're
building up the same structure but it
doesn't get executed right away instead
you build up this big sort of chain
together task you hand that off to main
and then the the language run time will
actually execute that when you start the
program
that's the only difference so it's
nothing mysterious it doesn't feel like
a totally different you know way of
doing effects it's just like kind of
like promises but you do that everywhere
now one important difference when it
comes to performance is that you do have
to do this for all effects so in a
language that supports side effects uh
you don't have to have promise for
everything sometimes you can just have a
normal function call that does side
effects whereas in the language with
managed effects every single effect is
done in this way with sort of this like
promise like wrapper
so really kind of the question comes
down to what is that overhead like we if
we have to have this sort of wrapper
around all of our effects like promise
or task whatever the case may be um how
significant of an overhead is that for
the language so basically what it boils
down to is that for both promise and
task they're essentially closures that
is to say functions that can sort of
capture the enclosing scope a little bit
um and then they have other closures
inside that's really all there is to it
they're basically just closures which is
to say that the overhead of wrapped
effects is pretty much just whatever the
cost of closures is in your particular
language now the thing is that overhead
can vary pretty dramatically like i
mentioned earlier one of the things that
can be potentially boxed which is to say
heap allocated which is to say taking a
lot longer than things that aren't boxed
um our functions or closures um
fortunately in the case of rock we were
able to do this um we don't box them
this is one of the many things that we
don't box
there's a whole you know topic of
de-functionalization and how we're able
to do that with direct calls instead of
function pointers which is really cool
but uh not the subject of this talk um
so to sum up in terms of managed effects
and the overhead that they have on the
language um task itself is unboxed the
unboxed task is essentially just a bunch
of closures inside other closures which
are also unboxed um and we have these
enumerated direct calls with
defunctionalization which all of which
basically means that the overhead of
this these like wrapped effects that we
have to do everywhere it's so minimal
that it's honestly not something we're
even worried about
now
that's when it comes to no side effects
so small in terms of overhead that we're
not worried about it
different story when it comes to
mutation
uh this is this is sort of the big one
like this is this is like the big
downside of pure functional programming
um is that um that this makes
performance optimization in some
scenarios a lot harder um so let's just
uh compare a mutation and non-mutation
version of something to sort of get an
idea for why this might be
so here is an imperative for loop so
we're saying that i equals zero i is
less than ray.length i plus plus and
then inside the body of the for loop
basically what we're doing is we're
saying every element of this array we're
just going to double it right there in
place
pretty simple operation here's what it
looks like if you don't have access to
mutation you're basically going to do a
map so a ray.map and then this is also
in javascript syntax
and then each element in the array we're
going to double it now this is going to
make an entirely new array so this sort
of no mutation version is definitely not
going to run as fast as the mutation
version mutation is going to be a lot
faster because it doesn't have to
allocate an entirely new array and write
all these values into this new array
that's maybe not in your memory cache
instead it's able to do everything in
place everything's going to probably be
in the cache already
it's just going to go faster so if you
have this use case where you're like
that's what i need for performance
there's really no substitute for
mutation in cases like this
um having said that it's worth noting
that there are some cases where actually
making the new array can net become a
performance optimization so i mentioned
that this was the sort of benchmark from
that sort of got me into elm in this
blog post and one of the things that
it's comparing here is essentially what
how how are these different frameworks
and languages able to optimize rendering
and as it turns out as you can see on
this chart like lower is better so the
smaller bars are running faster
all the ones at the bottom actually
require immutability for rendering and
they're able to be much faster than the
alternatives in large part because this
enables a very quick comparison check
between the old and the new state
and it's only able to do that because
you're actually making a new one if
there if you were doing in-place
mutation in place direct updates this
optimization would not work and these
things would be a lot slower in practice
than they actually are
so basically when the cost of
immutability which is a cost in this
case um is less than the sort of like
cost of rendering it can actually end up
working out to be a net performance
improvement uh which is exactly how
these
libraries and languages are able to win
at this benchmark um as far as i know
the first person to come up with this
like observation that this could be used
for performance optimization was uh
david nolan for closure script and then
evan shaflicky who made elm built on
that to basically produce the results of
that um that performance benchmark uh
that i showed a second ago okay now this
is a case where
by coincidence pure functional
programming just happens to nicely work
out to be a performance optimization
despite the fact that immutability is
all else being equal at cost but like i
said earlier some algorithms require
in-place mutation to run fast we cannot
get away from this there's just no
substitute for it if we want to to make
them run fast um and you know i asked
this question like how competitive can a
pure function language be at a mutation
heavy algorithm like quick sort
well let's let's actually look at
quicksort itself um so i'm choosing this
because it's a relatively well-known
algorithm not that it's the thing that
people are writing all the time but you
know we can kind of use it as a proxy
for uh like mutation-heavy algorithms in
general um so this is a very brief
animation of how quicksort works you
definitely don't need to remember how
all this works but the important part is
it's doing all these comparisons and
then at some point this is the key it
does this swap so it actually swaps in
place inside the array those two
elements and again there it's doing it
again so all the other comparisons kind
of could be fine in a pure functional
sense it's all you know relatively
immutable but that swap there's just no
substitute for doing that in place if
you want quick sort to basically be
quick sort and run fast
okay so here's an implementation of um
quicksort in javascript it's actually
just one part of it the partitioning
function i just want to look at this
real quick
we can kind of see all sorts of
imperative stuff happening here right
here's a for loop um it's calling this
swap function which is swapping things
in place it's incrementing something
mutating that doing another swap there's
just imperative stuff all over the place
in this uh implementation um this is
kind of like a textbook quick sort this
is not hand optimized like for
all of the quicksort examples i'm going
to talk through in this section none of
these are optimized at all it's all just
going to be like take quicksort out of a
textbook implement it done
okay
so uh talking about quicksort in a pure
functional language like haskell which
we saw earlier earlier is capable on its
own just because the overhead is so much
lower than something like ruby is
capable of outperforming um imperative
languages at some tasks like we saw at
work but how does it do in quicksort
well one of the things that haskell is
known for is this very concise quick
sort implementation
this is cool it's neat that you can
implement something that is
quick sortie um in this way but a pretty
reasonable objection to this is that
this is in no way shape or form
quicksort um so there's a whole blog
blog post about this where it's
basically like yeah the whole point of
quicksort is that it's fast because of
in place mutation this is just doing a
bunch of cloning it's not fast it's not
quick
so why are we considering this to be
quicksort which i think is a valid
criticism
but the blog post also goes on to say
okay challenge accepted let's try to
make one that does in place mutation in
haskell um so that one is slightly less
concise um here it is
but beyond the conciseness delta um
there's a much more concerning issue
which is that i'm just going to
highlight a couple of function calls we
have in here based on their names you
can guess why i might be concerned
unsafe read unsafe swap an unsafe slice
those don't sound safe
based on the names and indeed if you
look at the uh
what they're actually doing
this is imperative haskell we are
actually literally doing a
data.vector.generic.mutable
and we're in a pure functional language
or theoretically pure functional
we're actually doing like direct
in-place mutation and just hoping no no
no nobody notices it's going to be fine
everything's fine
so here's the the docs for unsafe slice
says like yield a part of the mutable
vector without copying it meaning if
somebody else mutates it it's going to
mutate my copy so referential
transparency is now gone no bounce
checks are performed so we're actually
now less safe than something like rust
we're in like c and c plus plus
territory where we might get
segmentation faults if we try to read
off the end of the array we might get
garbage memory
security problems uh this function's all
kinds of unsafe so it's a good thing
they put on safe in the title i
appreciate that
so this is uh
kind of cheating um we're it's actually
super cheating like we're just not doing
functional programming anymore um
but having said that okay okay fair
enough but
how does it perform
well
uh so i ran this against a number of uh
other programming languages and uh quick
sorting 10 million numbers um and also
doing running that 100 different times
and then sort of taking the average just
so we can kind of see how things look
all done on the same machine um so
javascript clocked in a little under 1.4
seconds haskell was actually slightly
faster than javascript which is
impressive
java was faster than haskell go was
faster than java and then c plus
unsurprisingly was the fastest so this
is all again just sort of textbook you
know unoptimized just writing out
quicksort according to the textbook or
in the haskell case doing this kind of
weird unsafe thing um but it does show
that it is it is possible for haskell to
beat these languages but again
not by using functional programming this
is just by sort of cheating and uh and
doing really dangerous things that i
don't think any hassler would recommend
that you do in production code unless
there's really absolutely no other
alternative having said that
it is good to know that if you need it
if you really need to do an imperative
algorithm like that you do have access
to that in haskell like you're not going
to be blocked you're not going to be
like oh i guess we got to rewrite in c
plus plus no you actually can do it and
it can be competitive in performance
with languages that are 100 imperative
that are imperative all the time not
just when you're sort of doing this
carve out um
the deltas that you see here like the
reason that some of these languages are
different is basically though although
there is the same algorithm you know
behind the scenes they're all doing
asymptotically the same thing there's
different language overheads that are
sort of accounting for these differences
um
worth noting that in this benchmark we
found that tweaks affect the overhead a
lot so i really don't want anyone to
look at that and be like oh java is
faster than javascript no this is not a
reasonable conclusion to take away
for example originally we had when we
did this we used java arraylist and
someone pointed out hey java array is
like much faster it's something like
this sure enough that was true that
really brought brought things down for
java we didn't consider that to be
really a performance optimization
because it's like either was a
reasonable choice
javascript originally we were sorting
64-bit integers and even though java has
like a javascript has a big num thing
now it turns out it's just still way
slower than double which is sort of
java's javascript's red and butter so go
figure we switched everything to double
so so is not to disadvantage javascript
and c plus is skipping bounce checks
maybe that's unfair to the other
language that's definitely memory unsafe
but that is kind of idiomatic c plus
plus so we figured well we're trying to
just do a straightforward implementation
here so that seemed fair again can't
emphasize this enough this is not a
rigorous comparison
this is really just to talk about you
know performance optimization and uh
pure functional languages
um
okay also note worth noting that um
interop is a much more common way to
solve like uncommon performance problems
like this like if i were writing haskell
and i found some algorithm that like
really really needed to be performance
optimized like they really needed that
in-place mutation i probably would not
go into this like mutable like let's
just throw all our guarantees out the
window land or if i if i have to then
i'm probably just going to do it by
doing interop with a much faster
imperative language like a low-level
systems level language c plus rust zig
something like that and this is what
most languages do i mentioned numpy
earlier in python the whole point of
that is it just goes down and talks to
like i think numpy is written in c um
but you know basically a lower level
language that's capable of you know
running as fast as you need
okay but what if we could do it with
optimizers instead instead of you know
cheating instead of like throwing all of
our guarantees out the window is there
some way that we can optimize our way
into getting that same level of
performance because optimizers are
pretty amazing things like um the the
first optimizing compilers included uh
fortran and apparently so i've told
people were actually surprised to find
that the code written through the
optimizing compiler actually ended up in
practice being faster typically than
code written by hand like an assembly
language people were really surprised by
this um there may come someday be a day
where you know much like with games like
chess and now go um humans are just
incapable of beating optimizers we're
definitely not there yet but it's
theoretically possible that we could get
there where you know you just can't
really catch up and also in the typical
case it's way faster let the optimizer
do it so if we can we would like to not
have to resort to things like interop or
you know these uh secret mutation you
know unsafe things um
so one example of a good optimization
that's really common and important in
functional languages is tail call
optimization this is something where we
don't need to drop down into other
languages we don't need to do unsafe
things we can just let the compiler sort
of translate pure functional code into
code that is equivalent to the
imperative counterpart so uh basically
any imperative loop like a while or a
four or anything like that
can be expressed this is there's a proof
somewhere i forget what it's called um
as a recursive function instead they're
both they're both like equivalent in
terms of expressive power um the
recursive function by default it has
very different runtime characteristics
but tail call optimization can detect
when it's possible to optimize that into
just the same thing in other words like
the exact machine instructions that you
get out the other side are going to be
identical whether you wrote a while loop
or you wrote a recursive function
so that's cool and that's sort of
promising
could we do the same thing here could we
make it so that we could take this
imperative for loop where we did
mutation in place for this array example
and make it so that the array.map
version optimizes to exactly the same
thing like same runtime characteristics
and the answer is yes but
you've got to be careful with that
because if we're doing things in place
it's not really immutable anymore
except it can be in one situation
like if those compile to the same
machine code and
we have to happen to be in the situation
where the thing that we're mapping over
is never referenced again for the rest
of the program
there's no downside it's never
referenced again yeah we're mutating in
place but no one ever sees that
like we're just reusing the same memory
and so it's still semantically immutable
we've still preserved all of our
guarantees everything's still
referentially transparent
but we're getting the runtime
performance of imperative in place
mutation
interesting interesting so this is the
idea of opportunistic in-place mutation
basically the compiler figuring out when
it's unobservable to change to in-place
mutation and then just doing that
similar to tail call optimization um so
this absolutely can be done
automatically one way to do it is by
using reference counting like we are
using in rock so basically the trick is
just reference count counts how many
times the thing is referenced if you're
about to do something that would
ordinarily be in
immutable clone and you realize wait a
minute the reference count is one that
means nobody else is referencing it so
let's go ahead and do it in place you
can totally do that um this does mean
that you need to be doing reference
counting instead of a tracing garbage
collector because the tracing garbage
collector doesn't have that information
it doesn't know how many uh references
you have to something so um that this
optimization when done in this way sort
of relies on that
as it turns out um very very often like
a whole lot of the time though um you
can actually do this statically like you
can detect
that the reference is going to be won at
this exact point because you can see
it's just never referenced for the rest
of the program
so this is basically a way to detect
many but not quite all but many very
many of the these in-place mutation
optimization opportunities at compile
time now this means that you don't
actually need to do the runtime
reference count checks which is good
because it works with all of the
different ways that rock can manage
memory not just reference counting
and it also means that we can do it for
unboxed values so only box values are
reference counted and which means that
you know if we're doing this the static
detection we can do it for any kind of
record for example
um
this also reduces runtime overhead in
general because it means we just don't
need to do this extra comparison to this
extra check at runtime to see if the
reference count is one we just already
know that it's safe to do it in place we
can just remove that conditional
altogether
um
the first version of this that we had
going uh was made by folk devries as
part of his um master's thesis at
radballer university sorry dutch people
i know it's pronounced differently
but he used uniqueness types and
inspired by the clean programming
language um and this worked this
actually was able to do the in-place
detection at compile time but uh we
found that it was kind of brittle and it
was actually like unfortunately easy to
de-optimize it and like make a change
somewhere in your program that caused
the optimization to no longer be able to
apply um so version two which is what
we're using today is based on alias
analysis using the morphic solver this
is a really cool library especially
academic folks you should check this out
these uc berkeley folks they did this in
undergrad
i played video games in undergrad uh
they've made a static in place mutation
detection optimization library and rust
that's like plugable into multiple
compilers one of which is the rock
compiler now i guess the first of which
is the rocking pile we've been sort of
collaborating with them um so really
appreciate all their hard work on this
um it's really cool and really is
helping out uh rock to achieve its goals
and performance um and uh so if you if
you're interested in that here's some
contact info to follow up with them um
cool so
pulling all this together i'm talking
about a lot of optimizations here a lot
of like you know overhead reduction um
how competitive can a pure function
language be at quicksort um well uh so
in terms of rock uh let's let's actually
implement quicksort in a pure functional
style like not cheating not resorting to
imperative stuff this is actually pure
functional quick sort for real
so we saw in the javascript version um
there was all these imperative stuff
there was like a for loop and there was
a swap in place and partitioning index
being incremented um but through the
stuff we've just talked about like tail
call elimination we can say okay we
don't actually need to do a for loop we
can just do a recursive function and
instead of doing this swap in place
maybe we can just do a swap that's
semantically immutable but hopefully can
get compiled to in-place mutation in
practice um so here's what partition
looks like in rock it is definitely
longer than the imperative version i'm
not gonna lie
um and it's also doing what appears to
be a lot more work like we're instead of
incrementing that thing with plus plus
we're actually returning a record that
has like the new index plus one the list
is doing a full swap which is you know
semantically is uh is immutable
returning a new list um we're returning
another record here um we're calling
this partition help function which is a
whole nother function um which is also
returning records and calling itself so
it's recursive um really just like
looking at these two side by side it's
clear that like yeah okay quick sort
this is not where functional programming
shines this is not where like like yeah
i can't wait to like write quicksort in
a pure functional style it's gonna be
really beautiful and elegant and concise
now this is actually pretty much a
pathological algorithm for pure
functional programming like it requires
in-place mutation um
to be fast and that's just like not
something that pure fp excels at it's
great at plenty of other things but this
is not it this is we're really at the
worst case scenario pretty much for for
pure functional programming but
we have this question where we saw in
the in the benchmark with haskell
haskell using imperative stuff was able
to
you know be competitive with these
imperative languages basically because
haskell has pretty low overhead overall
in fact it was even able to be slightly
faster than javascript um
where does rock end up when we're using
no no tricks no like secretly imperative
stuff no
interop just
pure functional programming
and a bunch of optimizations
turns out
really really fast
so this is pure functional programming
language it has no business being fast
at quicksort
and yet because of all these
optimizations that we're doing and like
all the low overhead that we've like
really been careful to bake in the
language um granted like i said this is
a pretty silly benchmark but um it's
real i mean this this actually we got it
to be faster than javascript haskell
haskell using cheats
java go and basically everything but c
plus plus um not gonna lie we just got
all of this working like two days ago
and uh like within an hour or two we
were like okay well like how do we close
that gap with c plus plus
uh
that'll be another talk hopefully that'd
be really cool but um but yeah i mean
basically the the way that we were able
to do this was by just optimizations um
which to me is like uh very exciting you
know it's fundamentally now we have the
same algorithm in terms of asymptotics
and just that difference in overhead we
were able to sort of bring that down as
well as possible meant that yeah i mean
even for problems like this where you
need in place mutation to be fast that's
achievable now
okay so to sum up all the optimizations
we sort of talked about here we have the
lvm optimizer this is doing all like
really low level stuff same thing that c
plus plus and rust in them and zig use
um that's doing a lot of heavy lifting
here for sure um unboxed values really
helps out the llcm optimizer um just not
doing these like heap allocations that
we don't need to um static reference
counting that was in use there so that
was all automatically memory managed
code
we can do even better with other memory
management strategies but it seemed like
for a fair comparison we shouldn't use
those here um tail call optimization
absolutely essential for quick sort
we tried actually doing it without tail
call optimization just to see what
happens and the answer is you just sit
and watch the computer do nothing for a
while and then eventually stack overflow
so don't recognize don't recommend that
um but uh but fortunately when you do
have it it's quite fast um and then
finally the real key that you know
without which this is just uh totally
hopeless is the opportunistic in-place
mutation now that's one of the things
that as far as i know rock is the only
functional programming language that's
sort of aimed at being like a real used
in industry language that's doing this i
think all the other languages that are
doing it are like academic research
languages
so we're excited to see what it can do
okay so let's summarize all the things
we talked about um so first you know
this this is a language that comes
directly from elm this is a direct
descendant of elm i've had this really
delightful experience using elm it's a
pure functional language that compiles
to javascript really great for
browser-based uis but i wanted to be
able to do sort of other things than
just browser-based uis with a similar
kind of feel of language um so those are
all the goals of rock uh you know
delightful experience i mean i didn't
talk about any experience stuff but i've
given some other talks on you know user
experience and uh ergonomics of rock
pure functional compiled binary um and
yet we still want to go fast you know
even though we're compiling to you know
binaries and competing with all the
other imperative languages that would do
that you know we'd really like to be uh
as as fast or faster than uh than sort
of our our contemporaries
there's three major performance
considerations to this so one is overall
language overhead and then there are
these sort of drawbacks to try and work
around like we can't have side effects
can't have mutation um so talked about
how you know overall language overhead
can sometimes just dominate and it
doesn't those other considerations just
don't matter like at work you know we
are migrating uh from ruby to haskell uh
most of our traffic now goes through
haskell and we saw about a 10x
improvement by the way uh we're hiring
if you're interested in working in
technologies like haskell and elm maybe
someday rock who knows um
and uh and so uh what we saw is that
we're able to sort of uh get language
overhead for rock as low as possible by
using lvm as our compilation back end um
using unboxed values basically
everywhere and by doing memory
management uh in these really low
overhead ways with static reference
counting um as well as these other novel
things that i mentioned in other talks
um we don't actually know to be fair
like how how well the static reference
counting is going to work at scale
because rock is a very work in progress
language it's like not really being used
for anything serious yet there are no
sufficiently big rock programs to say
that but so far we're feeling pretty
good about about the direction we're
going
um talked about side effects versus
managed effects so rock can't do side
effects but it does manage effects which
in practice feels about the same as
using promises
the only difference is that you know you
sort of have to use them everywhere for
every possible effect there is no like
non-promise or non-task way of doing
effects so really that comes down to
okay how efficient are those effects and
fortunately when we're doing unboxed
tasks unboxed closures and these
enumerated direct calls it turns out to
be so fast that in practice we're just
not worried about this being a
significant source of overhead for the
language
um on the other hand uh we talked about
immutability and so normally
immutability is by default a cost but we
have seen use cases some scenarios where
immutability at runtime like actually
you know creating new versions of values
can end up being a performance
optimization depending on the libraries
you're using and how quickly they can
potentially skip doing other work
so this is a good example in the browser
but we also talked about how that's it's
not always that convenient sometimes you
have algorithms that require in-place
mutation to run fast um and this is
where this sort of long list of
optimizations that we've got going on
enables us to compete with those um all
of this sort of culminating in in our
exciting results of actually being able
to be faster at quick sort which is
pathologically hard and bad for pure
functional programming um written in a
pure functional style and actually out
competing successfully um these
imperative languages that are sort of in
their wheelhouse
um
so hopefully we've now seen a couple
different examples of ways that pure
functional programming actually can out
compete outperform imperative at various
different tasks in some cases like with
the the rendering in the browser it's
just because pure functional programming
happens to be well suited to doing that
in a high performance way in other cases
it's just because of baseline language
overhead has nothing to do with paradigm
like our haskell outperforming ruby at
work um and in some cases it's just
through sort of a sheer force of
optimizations that we're able to say
yeah even though this task is not
innately well suited to pure functional
programming we can make the downside be
just that it's less concise and you know
more to read but not that it's slower in
fact it can actually still be capable of
outperforming other garbage collected
languages
and hopefully now you have an idea of
how you actually can outperform
imperative with pure functional
languages thanks very much
[Music]
you